en fait il faut que je te dise le
premier jour je t'ai vu à la télé j'ai
arrêté toutes les conneries tu vois tout
ce qui est
[Musique]
nathalie andréani est devenu l'une des
stars de ces plateformes inscrite depuis
deux ans elle fait aujourd'hui entre 100
et 150 mille euros de chiffre d'affaires
par mois
nathalie à 51 ans elle passe deux heures
par jour à la salle de sports la scène
sera en salles en fait parce que ça
reste correction vitrine pour moi c'est
un élément le travail donc je peux pas
me permettre de prendre 5 kg et de
laisser aller c'est impossible comment
comment est-ce qu'on passe de cyclades
story au porno alors tout simplement
j'ai toujours le culte du corps j'ai été
approché par des marques de lingerie
pour faire de la publicité on avait très
très critiqué sur les réseaux sociaux et
à force d'être critiqué c'est vrai que
j'avais beaucoup de demandes de la part
de certains hommes qui voulant voir un
petit peu plus sûr je me suis dit tiens
je vais créer un compte instagram que je
vais fermer je vais faire payer l'entrée
à l'époque je faisais payer 10 euros
l'entrée et geoffrey des photos de
lingerie les choses très très sexy sauf
que évidemment instagram a eu vent de
cette aventure ils m'ont fermer mon
compte et on m'a parlé doniphan voilà je
suis parti sur cette plateforme j'ai
évolué tout doucement c'est à dire que
j'ai commencé par la lingerie et puis
j'aime montrer mais ça je suis montrée
nue et chez beaucoup d'art c'est très
artistique ce que j'ai très jeune je ne
juge pas je sais que c'est veut donc
c'est pas votre fille qui vous filmer
tout ça mais forcément votre fille quand
elles vont sur le site tel vous vois moi
ou ma mère encore non mes filles vont
pas sur ces sites à l on pas que c'est
elles vont sur mon instagram annonce
puisque les quais face sur mon talent à
malause forcément déjà vu personne
curieuse étudiants même à faire du porno
des filières de l vois mes photos sexy
et elle voit je vais vous dire mieux la
première fois que j'ai vendu des photos
topless avait fait des photos avec un
photographe et c'est une de mes filles
qui m'a dit maman tu vas sur les réseaux
sociaux tu vas trouver des actrices des
chanteuses pour la poitrine à l'air moi
ce qui me choque c'est pas forcément le
fait qu'elle vous prennent en sous
vêtements etc parce qu'en bon que ça
encore ça va mais c'est le fait que en
faisant ça elle participe un peu à vos
vidéos qui sont plus at ça veut dire
qu'elle accepte parce que si elle
accepte que vous soyez en string un peu
embêté moi très sexy dans l'épreuve un
peu suggestives comme ça veut dire
qu'elle accepte aussi le plus le porno
les vidéos
mais j'aurais jamais cru un jour être
qu'une femme déjà de son âge et puis
surtout d'une telle beauté au début on
n'était pas vraiment ensemble c'était
juste on se voyait de temps en temps
comme ça quand on avait envie quand
j'avais envie
et un jour je lui ai dit je vais plus
partagé je te ferai pour moi c'est vrai
cctc gratuite l'état du malade tu mets
un peu cette histoire d'amour quand même
non non non c'était si gratuite et
d'heures mathieu avant tout ça j'ai une
surprise pour toi comme tu es mon client
numéro un de son mime j'ai un petit
cadeau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors
attends d'accord
[Applaudissements]
tu as la planche du fakir tu dois savoir
où l'on va arriver sur les abdos 1 3
partout hu a même été magnifique c'est
bien aux gens parce que tout le monde
connait pas pardon c'est quoi mims
c'est un site de sexuel
donc tu t'es sorti
pour prendre tout va si du côté sur mym
pardon tu t'es tu n'as qu'à ça non mais
quel corps pour
beaucoup même l'école et si quelqu un
clin d'oeil à faire n'hésitez pas à
l'époque y avait cette histoire avec
nathalie tu étais vraiment amoureux mois
s'il faut savoir c'est que j'étais
vraiment gros nathalie secretstory ils
nous ont demandé des preuves comme quoi
un thème ensemble ce qui est beaucoup
truc fait qu'à l'époque on avait deux
ans de photos et on a été pris donc du
coup voilà c'est un truc moi je suis
venu ici c'est que pour deborah voilà
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] du reste des ces
voix là en fait il faut que je te le
dise le premier jour que tu as vu à la
télé j'ai arrêté toutes les conneries tu
vois tout ce qui est voilà un porno
claquettes chaussettes et ou devant la
télé c'est fini c'est pourquoi ça me
gêne parce que j'ai fait le sujet tu te
prépares tu as fait ton coming out ya
quelques
instants du coup j'avais pas fan coming
out non c'était une blague qu'on a vu
avec un seul le vainqueur
non vraiment amoureux des bons noms mais
en fait hébreu depuis que j'ai vu j'ai
changé voilà donc j'avais été invité à
dunkerque chez ma mère s'est dit prêt à
tenir en cas des deux séries en effet
une fiche de moi si tu veux dire tu
imagerie quéven nouveau surprise et j'ai
aimé lebon mathieu sortir je peux
laisser passer c'est sur cette belle
parole puisque des bras maintenant tu es
en couple et
[Applaudissements]
surtout bébé on en parle était amoureuse
de
maintenance et une autre qui viennent
d'être une balle par mois bakhit l'a
piqué qu'est-ce qui gisent comme
restera heureusement si tôt votre secret
découvert vous avez pu enfin vivre un
véritable conte de fées
[Musique]
ça va mais je peux me reposer un petit
peu tu veux moi pas en couple
un amour indestructible basé sur
l'échangé la communication
mais tu tombe vraiment amoureux de
thomas
et soeurs on est trente secondes pour se
traiter frères et soeurs et je commence
à tomber amoureuse de lui sauf que le
secret est pas encore découvert par les
autres habitants de la maison donc on se
retrouve demain tout simplement à avoir
cette relation moi je suis amoureuse de
vie mais je ne peux le dire à personne
parce qu'on ne peut pas être amoureuse
de son frère non et du coup huit
semaines après le secret est découvert
et du coup je peux lui annoncer que je
suis amoureuse de lui et je suis trop
contente et je veux prend le vent de
l'année devant 5 millions de
téléspectateurs
qui lui il était à ba2 à il est très
amoureux de lui depuis très longtemps
[Rires]